attends attends attends quitte la garoup
E
gardez tous les magasins qui sont fermés
et tout le monde a commencé à courir
j'ai couru je crois qu'il y avait un
coup de feu et tout je crois qu'on
allait mourir j'ai tellement peur ah là
là ma chérie excusez-moi
s'il te plaît mets-le là parce que vous
voyez bien qu'il y a 7 personnes vous
voyez bien
merci
Sandrine responsable d'un magasin la
défense tout le monde a entendu parler
de cette histoire c'était samedi vers
17h OK
[Rires]
donc forcément sinon tu vas je te
regarde à toi oui mais ça va passer et
c'est comme ça
très bien calme-toi j'apprends en train
de tomber amoureux
lundi pas en direct c'est ça sympa s'il
vous plaît on va parler d'un sujet
sérieux samedi vers 17h vous étiez dans
votre magasin Sandrine avec votre équipe
quand tout à coup vous entendez des cris
merci tout à fait alors
il paraît que ça a été la panique totale
le mot est faible ah ouais vraiment
ouais c'est la plus grosse peur de votre
vie
très honnêtement
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé donc vous êtes
dans le magasin tranquille vous entendez
quoi parce que on a vu des mouvements de
foot de fou j'ai vu la défense tout le
monde parlait que de la défense
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pour vous en fait vous comment vous avez
ressenti le truc
les deux premières secondes on ne
comprend pas ce qui se passe vous voyez
quoi des gens crier partout des gens
pourris des gens qui tombent des sacs
qui volent on comprend pas vraiment ce
qui se passe
et ensuite on reprend ses esprits ce
qu'on a une certaine responsabilité
on pense à ce qu'on a pu voir ou
entendre les mesures de sécurité les
choses comme ça parce que bien
évidemment
on nous donne pas d'informations plus
que ça donc moi j'ai mis à l'abri mon
équipe ainsi que les clients qui se
trouvaient dans mon magasin
on pense pas vraiment Cyril
je pense que c'est surtout ça ouais
pour vous il s'est passé quoi alors
samedi alors si vous me le permettez moi
je suis là pour ne pas dire ce que je
fais ce que je crois ou ce que je ne
crois pas je suis très en colère sur la
manière dont on minimise ce qui s'est
passé samedi alors
samedi alors on va on va entendre la
version de Bruno Pommard qui est la
version voilà qu'on a tous entendu on
noter les spectateurs vous allez nous
dire après vous comment vous avez
ressenti l'événement enfin l'événement
le tristement Bruno qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé samedi à 17h à la défense alors il
y a un fait divers enfin de compte
c'est-à-dire un suicide puisque on voit
un personnage tombé évidemment s'écraser
sur le sol donc avec un bruit qu'on
imagine pas et ce bruit que vous avez
entendu
au cinquième cinquième étage donc ça
fait une chute tu vois un petit peu la
distance et le bruit surtout lorsque
l'impact du corps sur le donc ça ça
définit un petit peu la je dirais tout
ce que le fantasme aussi mais ça c'est à
dire évidemment vous avez raison d'avoir
paniqué je comprends des gens qui
pensent que c'est un bruit d'armes parce
que ça fait d'ailleurs la plupart n'ont
pas dû entendre un bruit d'armes mais ça
fait un tel claquement que ça fait sa
terroriste tout le monde lorsqu'il y a
certaines impact donc c'est des
personnes effectivement il y a
l'évacuation vous savez que vous avez
des normalement des consignes en termes
vous avez un magasin de fermer les
magasins et de protéger votre voilà ça
c'était important c'est une c'est la
base même de la sécurité en cas de de
grosses problématique ensuite qu'est-ce
qui se passe il y a une évacuation qui
se fait et évidemment un nombre avec un
risque de piétinement qui est c'est pas
comment on est passé à près de près
d'une catastrophe il faut le dire mais
quoi qu'il en soit ça c'est relativement
bien passé même bien passé puisqu'il y a
pas eu de blesser grave et là il y a
quelque chose qui est intéressant
heureusement il y a des gens qui sont
conscients encore dans des moments comme
ça c'est pas toujours évident je l'avoue
il y a des jeunes qui se sont rendus
directement auprès d'une vous savez que
des brigades de territoriales de contact
qui existe c'est-à-dire des policiers
qui patrouillent compagnie de
sécurisation d'intervention qui
patrouille sur le parvis de la Défense
et ils étaient positionnés au niveau de
l'aquare Arena et deux jeunes sont venus
au contact de jeunes très apeurés vous
avez raison puisque vous disiez que vous
avez peur ils sont venus au contact de
ces policiers pour leur dire voilà il y
a un homme qui est mort et qui s'est
fait abattre parce que les gamins ont
entendu ce bruit effectivement tout le
monde c'est un meurtre
voilà les deux policiers dont de cette
fameuse BTC qui appartient à Nanterre se
sont rapprochés de l'entrée du site avec
du matériel lourd
un bouquet balistique et un fusil
d'assaut G36 évidemment pour accompagner
pour aller au contact évidemment de ce
qui se passait entre temps ils ont
rencontré une autre compagnie une autre
équipe de la compagnie de sécurisation
une intervention donc quatre
fonctionnaires de police qui sont
rentrés à contre courant de ce qui se
passait puisque tous les gens sortaient
et là c'est très compliqué il faut
saluer nos policiers encore une fois là
parce qu'ils ont pris des risques
considérables tu peux le faire Cyril
crois-moi parce que c'est à quatre
rentrées comme il faut avec des gens qui
viennent en face paniquer avec un G36
avec
une visée laser pour aller peut-être
contact de éventuellement de terroristes
on a vu des images assez folles où les
fausses de l'ordre demande aux gens de
lever les mains en passant pour vérifier
allez-y allez-y doucement
sereinement et en sécurité
alors
vous Sandrine vous avez entendu ce qu'a
dit Bruno on va voir ce que dit un
témoin aussi qui dit que l'homme s'est
jeté de lui-même regardez
[Musique]
il a couché
il est tombé de quel étage en fait
c'est intéressant ce que dit la dame
parce que les interprétations que font
les gens et ça c'est dangereux c'est
même pour les policiers on a le 17 tout
le monde sait que le 17 il y a un
problème pourriez pas imaginer pas le
nombre d'appels au 17 qui ont eu les
gens c'est-à-dire première un premier
moment c'était équipe même dont je vous
parle les quatre premiers ce qu'on
appelle les prix moins intervenants dans
ce cas après sont arrivés évidemment des
effectifs importants ces quatre
personnes ces quatre policiers qui sont
intervenues pour essayer éventuellement
de neutraliser ou de trouver un
agresseur ont entendu à la radio qui
avait un homme retranché dans le magasin
Sephora voyez un petit peu les
informations qui partent de la salle de
commandement et qui arrive aux policiers
qui sera quatre avec leur fusil d'assaut
et qui progresse tant bien que mal dans
ce magasin ils vont au contact du
Sephora le Sephora est fermé puisque on
demande à fermer on demande aux gérant
d'ouvrir le le paravent pour que les
policiers puissent filtrer les gens et
les faire sortir il savait qu'il y avait
pas de se dotéroïste ou de tueurs
ensuite un autre appel arrive et là
c'est chez Apple
qui s'est avéré aussi faux ensuite
Athlon c'était pas Atlan c'était
Décathlon on aurait vu une personne un
homme avec un fusil longue portée il y a
un petit peu et oui le fantasme des gens
je peux le concevoir je dis aux gens
taisez-vous napolé que si vous avez des
éléments probants évidemment mais vous
voyez un petit peu tout ce qui peut
fuser dans la tête et les policiers
là-dessus je peux vous assurer que était
compliqué pour eux
Sandrine elle y était alors vous
Sandrine vous n'êtes pas contente
pourquoi pourquoi alors moi ce que
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique alors je
peux l'entendre le corps un corps qui
tombe fait énormément de bruit ce que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est qu'il y
a eu deux mouvements de foule
on a entendu à trois reprises le même
bruit donc
si je réfléchis bêtement peut-être ce
corps est tombé trois fois Monsieur non
écoutez moi je les informations que je
les ai sont probantes j'invente rien du
tout j'ai pas entendu les bruits j'étais
pas donc je peux vous assurer que
l'individu il y a une chute bien
déterminée l'individu a même été palpé
si vous voulez que j'aille un peu plus
loin pour voir s'il y avait pas des
impacts de bal ou autre dans ça a été
fait par la police évidemment mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il y a rien
qui dit que ça attention attention
le côté complotiste je lis pas vous
madame mais de penser que il y a des
choses qui se passent voilà si un
règlement de compte entre dealer ou quoi
ça se passe pas dans un centre
commercial comme ça je vous le dis comme
ça ils ont pas besoin de ça ils ont des
parking il y a ce qu'il faut un attentat
terroriste bah il y aurait pas eu
comment vous en doutez bien vous voyez
sûrement une série de de personnes qui
ont été tués donc voilà et c'est les
informations que j'ai qui sont probantes
alors vous sont qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire vous qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait depuis samedi nous ce qu'on
enfin ce que tout le monde voit sur les
réseaux
et si moi j'étais présente un j'ai
assisté à la scène
quand on entend oui mais non en fin de
compte c'est juste un suicide non ça n'a
pas été qu'un suicide il y a quand même
eu à plusieurs reprises des mouvements
de enfin de foule B des gens on leur a
marché dessus il y a eu des blessés bien
sûr moi j'ai eu une personne qui a lâché
un sac de cours j'ai eu un flacon enfin
une bouteille d'huile qui est tombée
devant mon magasin j'ai une jeune fille
qui est arrivée en courant elle est
tombée les pompiers sont arrivés enfin
il faut pas minimiser la chose comme
quoi il n'y a eu qu'un suicide non
ensuite et là je alors je vais être très
honnête Cyril quand je suis arrivée cet
après-midi quand j'ai pris la décision
de venir je devais venir sous le nom de
Chantal avec une perruque enfin voilà
j'ai pris la décision de venir en tant
que Sandrine parce que vous êtes
Sandrine parce que je suis
journaliste et que j'assume que j'assume
parfaitement ce que je suis en train de
dire et ce que je suis en train de faire
c'est que
qu'on nous dise vraiment les choses la
vérité qu'on qui prennent conscience que
la sécurité d'un centre commercial c'est
hyper important
je comprends mais sachez qu'un corps une
fois il y a des procès interventions
vous avez la Brigade de Recherche
intervention qui est spécialisée dans ce
type de les compétences il y a le raid
mais le raid peut venir un soutien mais
là en l'occurrence c'est la mairie Paris
qui peut intervenir donc il y a des
unités spécialisées qui sont arrivées
après un renfort évidemment les
effectifs conséquents mais ce que je
vous parle là c'est le travail qui est
qui a été fait a été fait correctement
par la police ça ne pensait pas un seul
moment que la police le préfet de police
s'est déplacé d'ailleurs Laurent munès
je veux dire les choses ont été faites
dans le dans les règles s'il y avait eu
des des véritables attentat ça se serait
pas passé comme ça
je comprends pas en fait
vous avez le sentiment qu'on vous a
caché quelque chose très honnêtement
d'autres d'autres personnes
un règlement de compte qui a
effectivement bien eu des coups de feu
mais qu'on ne veut pas le dire
enfin voilà moi je enfin
vous pensez pour l'image du centre
commercial
je pense ouais
bien sûr
et quand on veut se suicider on se
suicide il y en a tous les jours des
suicides
effectivement
l'autre coup que vous avez entendu c'est
pas l'écho du corps qui est tombé
à 5 minutes d'intervalle à 5 minutes
mais Sandrine dites-moi vous avez
d'autres témoignages qui recoupent ce
que vous dites il y a d'autres
commerçants qui vous ont dit est-ce que
ce n'est pas un triple coup de feu
finalement c'est à ça que vous pensez
très honnêtement mais monsieur venez à
la défense aller discuter avec mes
collègues et tout le monde vous dira
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'il y aura eu trois coups de feu c'est
ça
n'a pas été qu'un simple suicide vous
savez là aujourd'hui ce que je suis en
train de faire
je pense qu'il va y avoir des retombées
monsieur j'en suis sûre je mets en
doute la sécurité du centre c'est autre
chose
c'est autre chose règlement de compte
quand même à la défense un samedi
après-midi enfin voilà je veux dire
Sandrine c'est que vous aviez senti des
failles dans la sécurité ou pas
et là vous pensez que c'est une
résultante de ce que vous ce que vous
ressentiez et ça n'engage
que vous mais plutôt de commerçants dont
exactement est-ce que vous pensez que le
suicide a un rapport avec les coups de
feu qui aurait eu ou ces deux histoires
qui sont passées
c'est ça que je veux que je ne croyez
pas la véracité de ce que viendra le
relater mais je ne demande qu'à le
croire alors est-ce que
les informations qui arrivent à la salle
de commandement au 17 c'est terrible
pour les policiers de faire du
discernement et surtout pour ceux qui
progressent plutôt blessés est-ce que
est-ce qu'on vous a parlé de blessés de
personnes qui ont repris une balle ou un
truc comme ça non donc vous auriez
entendu quoi alors il y a eu des blessés
le mouvement les mouvements de foule oui
donc non ce que vous êtes en train de
dire si si j'essaie de
décrypter de décrypter
donc il y a eu des coups de feu que la
personne a pris peur et c'est jeté du
cinquième c'est ça que vous en train de
dire je ne suis pas la seule non mais
c'est ça
que vous pensez d'accord
éventuellement on aurait attendu les
bruits
et ensuite il y a quand même un
intervalle qui se passe et il y a eu un
autre bruit et ce que je suis en train
de vous dire là alors à part si la
défense samedi après-midi était une
annexe de gens qui étaient pas alors oui
je comprends le fantasme des gens on a
envie de faire plein de choses ça je le
coup mais moi j'y étais je veux dire je
les ai entendu
non monsieur
à la chute de ce de cet individu
évidemment sur le sol c'est terrible
est-ce que récemment vous aviez eu vent
d'une situation compliquée au centre
commercial qui pourrait les supprimer
voilà et ce qui a eu du démonaces c'est
ce qu'il y a eu du trafic est-ce que
vous avez eu peur il y a déjà quelques
temps de ce qui est advenu selon vous
samedi
qui est alors je veux comprendre votre
question qui a un rapport avec ce qui
s'est passé samedi oui éventuellement
est-ce que ça vous étonne pas finalement
parce qu'il y a eu des menaces ou un
trafic de drogue a cru non ça non non
l'insécurité du centre on la connaît non
maintenant ce que dit son nom elle dit
qu'elle aille voilà elle pense qu'il y a
une autre version parce que elle pense
que voilà l'image oui c'est ça on
parlait pour l'image après voilà après
c'est c'est c'est ça
je pourrais pas vous dire une chose non
je coupe la parole je suis désolé mais
je ne connais pas vous dire c'est ce que
vous êtes en train un peu de nous dire
qu'il y a un espèce de qui n'est pas dit
en fait au niveau des retours de la
police du tout mais voilà
c'est déjà qu'il monte selon vous je ne
suis pas la seule à le penser et je vous
invite pleinement
il y aura les caméras moi je trouve ça
très fort soyez mais c'est vrai que je
pense aussi qu'avec l'émotion on voilà
[Musique]
à partir du moment où ils sont à
l'entrée du du centre commercial ou les
gens viennent en face à eux ils sont
quatre à progresser quand on progresse
on se protège un binôme on se protéger
hein qui qui se découvre l'autre qui
protège bref c'est c'est une complexité
je l'ai eu au téléphone je les connais
c'est des copains ça a été pour eux un
grand moment de voilà de bravoure je
dirais bon ils ont fait ce qu'il fallait
ils ont bien fait et ça serait
intéressant d'ailleurs même d'entendre
les deux jeunes parce que les deux
jeunes ont été courageux ont eu le
réflexe d'aller voir des policiers et de
dire il se passe quelque chose là-bas
avec un dérapeute effectivement mais
c'est des moments je vous dis
d'intensité énorme moi j'en ai connu
lors d'intervention effectivement on
peut considérer que le choc émotionnel
pour vous a été très fort merci Sandrine
en tout cas d'être venu nous voir on
espère que voilà ça va bien se passer
quand même pour vous centre commercial
on reviendra vous voir d'accord avec
plaisir j'aimerais changer le Verdez
si Sandrine en tout cas